my name is Tess ski and I'm a junior
here at Hillsdale College and I'm with
Churchill fellow studying politics I'm
here tonight to welcome mr. Richard
langworth to the stage mr. Richard
langworth is a senior fellow for the
hills oak colleges Churchill project in
1968 he organized the Churchill study
Union in its journal finest hour to
study churchill commemorative postage
the study unit leader became the
international Churchill society devoted
to studying Churchill's life mr.
langworth served as its president the
editor of finest hour and the chairman
of its board of trustees in 1995 the
Society changed its name to the
Churchill Center he is the author and
editor of numerous books including all
will be well
good advice from Winston Churchill
Churchill by himself in his own words
and most recently Winston Churchill myth
in reality what he actually did and said
in 1998 he was appointed a commander of
the most excellent Order of the British
Empire please join me in welcoming
Richard langworth
[Applause]
so I thank Tess and I thank you all for
attending I hope you all seen the film
this afternoon I have five points to
make about it the first is why Henry the
fifth is important in understanding
Churchill I differ in this from some of
my colleagues
the second is Churchill's familiarity
with Shakespeare he quotes no English
author and more the third is his
friendship with Sir Laurence Olivier
fourth what did Churchill most admire in
the film and finally I'll offer some
parallels between the story Shakespeare
told and Churchill story three centuries
over three centuries later first was
Henry the fifth in portney the
television producer Marlowe Lewis said
the play introduces us to urgent
problems of statesmanship and threw them
to questions of political philosophy the
delicate matters of legitimacy and the
founding of regimes I think that is an
aspect but not the most important aspect
above that in first the importance of
Henry the fifth is what it teaches us
about leadership true leadership right
Sandra Roberts stirs us in a way that is
deeply embedded in our genes and psyche
if the underlying factors of leadership
have remained the same for centuries
cannot these lessons be learned and
applied in situations far removed from
ancient times leadership like courage
and even sincerity can be completely
divorced from the concepts of good and
evil Robert says Hitler was both brave
and sincere in his beliefs despite the
fact that they were Wilson the greatest
criminal our own times Osama bin Laden
is a leader nonetheless deserving of our
investigation into how he could persuade
so many people to wreak so much
devastation only to study the leadership
of people whose actions one
Ruth would be to deny oneself the
examples of some of the world's most
influential leaders
fortunately Henry the fifth was a leader
for the good at least insofar as Olivia
taking certain liberties with the script
portrays him now at Churchill and
Shakespeare how well did Churchill know
the bard well enough I think to ASA
Hillsdale course on Shakespeare both by
formal quotations and by well-known
phrases almost hidden in his text
Churchill draws allusions and
understanding from 16 Shakespeare plays
from Macbeth to A Midsummer Night's
Dream though not surprisingly the
sonnets but he memorized at least five
plays verbatim in his book Churchill's
literary allusions Darrell Hawley
devotes a chapter to 50 of Shakespeare's
a church of Shakespeare references in
the speech to the General Assembly
Richmond Virginia in March 1946 after
the famous iron curtain speech in Fulton
Churchill explain why the bard was
relevant
he said the light of the Elizabethan age
which Shakespeare Rollie and Grenville
adorned casts its unfading luster upon
our scene here and in Williamsburg
nearby unfading luster is certainly
something both Shakespeare and Churchill
may claim sherek spiritual apply
Shakespeare to ornament and punctuate
his thought often he doesn't even bother
with quote marks he assumed in an age
when even grammar school children read
the Bard
that his listeners would recognize the
words ignorantly I once recalled
Churchill's an accredited Churchill with
for God's sake let us sit upon the
ground and tell sad stories of the death
of kings I was quickly admonished it is
of course from richard ii church's
understanding of western civilization
was strongly grounded in shakespeare and
other classics speaking at harvard in
1943 he defined what Americans and
Britons shared
blah language literature common
conceptions of what is right and decent
the marked regard for fair play
especially to the weak in the poor ass
Thorin sentiment of impartial justice
and above all the love of personal
freedom these themes are rights in the
works of Shakespeare Churchill and
Olivier Sir Laurence along with his
contemporary sir Ralph Richardson Dame
Peggy Ashcroft and Sir John Gielgud
dominated the British stage in the mid
20th century Olivier played in more than
50 films and later had great success in
television as far as we can tell he came
to church's attention in 1929 when the
actor was only 22 you know RC Sherriff's
blockbuster play journey's end
he played Captain Stanhope with
depressive alcoholic commanding British
troops in World War one hills dales the
Churchill documents contained sheriff's
letter thanking church' for his praise
the play and subsequent film must have
reminded Churchill of his own time in
the trenches although he was neither an
alcoholic and nor depressive despite
what you may have heard in 1939
Churchill met Merle Oberon who had
married Alexander Korda whom we heard
about earlier she had played Kathryn
opposite Olivier's Heathcliff in
weathering Heights it was a long
friendship ten years later as beaver
Brooks guests on the Riviera Church of
gave over in painting lessons every once
in a while he would look at her painting
and add a few brushstrokes of his own
the friend said the picture when
completed was excellent for a beginner
and about 80% Churchill nevertheless he
signed the inscription Merrill from
Winston s Churchill August 21 1949 the
next evening he suffered his first
stroke in 1940 after starring together
in lady Hamilton
Olivier and Vivian Leigh married they
often invited the Churchill's to
Lawrence's stage performances
watching Richard the third Church of
almost through the actor off by reciting
the words from the seat later he
admitted he knew the play by heart and
then recited twenty speeches from his
favorite Shakespeare tragedies
one after the other without a mistake
when olivier consulted him about the
delivery of a certain speech Churchill
gave a rendering which he thought better
than his own and subsequently adopted it
one Sunday evening at Chartwell in 1948
the chosen movie was Olivier's Hamlet a
Churchill favorite throughout the
performance wrote his friend Jack
Fishman two voices could be heard
declaiming the lines Olivier's from the
screen and Winston's from the audience
that dinner he continued to decline
passages but he did not need the script
to prompt him from the mid-40s the
Olivier's in church who were very close
bodyguard had Edmund Murray seconded to
Chartwell in 1950 remembered an after
lunch excursion to the fish pond a
special privilege I can remember mr.
Churchill telling them that each of the
maggots he fed his goldfish had a
pedigree and they should really consider
feeding them themselves from the tin lid
that he offered them in 1955 Churchill
paid Sir Laurence the ultimate accolade
inducted him into the other Club olivier
thanked him for sharing the joy of your
company in 1958 the producer Harry
towers signed olivier to narrate a movie
version of Churchill's history of the
english-speaking peoples he never found
the backer possibly being as John Fleet
said yesterday because you're talking
about 2,000 years worth of moody script
and the film remains unproduced to this
day but Olivier was there at sir
Winston's funeral reading fsor excerpts
from his speeches on the BBC it had
enormous impact one historian observed
some saw it as the funeral of the
British Empire some of the Requiem for
The Herald
of the war and others is the burial of
my tea subject in the nation's final
hero what is certain is that it could
have happened for no one else
Churchill and Henry v in April 1941
Churchill's government promoted a
patriotic short-film words for battle
intended as a rallying rallying cry
it featured poetry by Kipling Milton and
Blake and excerpts from speeches by
Lincoln and prime minister all were read
by Laurence Olivier against footage of
the Blitz as it ran in London a bomb
shot at the House of Commons one year to
the day since Churchill had become Prime
Minister 1944 Olivier joined Philippe
del Giudice to produce Henry v in
Technicolor Churchill enthusiastically
endorsed the project how could he not he
loved Shakespeare loved Olivier and
loved collar films the timing was right
filming began just before another great
invasion of France Operation Overlord in
the event the film was not released
until November 22nd a week or so after
church who had marched in liberated
Paris on Armistice Day the p.m. saw the
film with his wife and daughter Sarah on
the 25th his reaction his private
secretary recorded was ecstatic
Churchill in his history describes King
Henry as a gleam of splendor in the dark
troubled story of medieval England he
came to the throne at a moment when
England was we read of feuds and brawl
and yearned for unity and fame
Churchill could be thinking of himself
when he adds that Henry led the nation
away from internal discord to foreign
conquest he had the dream and perhaps
the prospect of leading all Western
Europe into the high championship of a
crusade the film was shot in Ireland and
hailed for its colourful sets and
costumes for our Olivier's masterful
direction and acting Pauline Kael called
it a triumph of color music spectacle
and soaring heroic
poetry in ur nominations for Best
Picture Best Actor the score at best
interior decoration in color olivier
received the special award for
outstanding achievement as actor
producer and director as we saw the
movie opens with a panorama of 1600
london and the globe theatre where the
audience is seated the king enters and
receives a gift from the french dolphin
tennis balls a snide jab at his youth in
an experience search we call this scene
in 1956 during a post stalin thought
with the russians
Khrushchev sent him cases of liquor from
different parts of the Soviet Union they
tasted said private secretary Anthony
Montagu Brown like alcoholic hair-oil
Sir Winston compared the gift to the
tennis balls from the dolphin to henry v
the film gradually moves from the Globe
Theatre in to stylized sets that look
like scenes from funhouse these
contrasted with lifelike battle scenes
very bright and somewhat larger than
life at Agincourt the nimble English
archers whose bow fingers the French had
vowed to cut off let's fly a volley of
arrows that devastates the clumsy
unwieldy French Knights according to
legend the victorious English held up
their still intact both fingers to this
humiliated French giving rise to the
famous D sign palm out that is pawn in
its a rude gesture in this country we
render it with one finger
after the battle Henry courts the French
Princess Catherine Renee Asher son King
Charles adopts Henry as a successor in
France falls under the sway of England
Olivier and del Giudice intentionally
left out Henry's harsher traits that
Shakespeare described them beheading
traitors threatening to pillage our
floor cutting the throats of prisoners
Shakespeare's melancholy epilogue on how
England under Henry the sixth lost
France is gracefully omitted reviewers
were admiring them but if
Google modern reviews you'll find they
still are the blogger Caillou sees a
world war two analogy Scots Welshman and
Englishman join in the common cause he
writes turn those archers in the
Spitfire pilots and the French Knights
in the German bombers and it all comes
together the French come across as
friendly toward England but corrupted
but for leadership sounds familiar
take the dolphin take the dolphin and
replace him with Hitler same thing the
camera work is dynamic was lots of
tracking and panning there's a
particularly breathtaking tracking shot
from the side of a French first French
charge the horse of slowly gathering
speed from a plot to a full gallop
it looks majestic in quote Olivier says
another reviewer seems the current
cultural epitome of classical
Shakespeare the camera movement reminds
one of scorsese and makes the space feel
so intimate the bridge between
Elizabethan England and our own doesn't
seem that long and if you watch henry v
with the right set of eyes it's an
absolute delight
there are many fine performances no bad
ones these are not Hollywood stars
sloppily mouthing Shakespearean titles
to justify their star power these are
experienced
Experion actors the archbishop is a
windbag king of Francis an absent-minded
old man the dolphin is an arrogant cult
ordered Marasco the Duke of Burgundy a
schemer Princess Catherine is
mischievous and naive shocked by a gross
and vile English sounds the only jarring
thing is the staunchly British
pronunciations of all the French words
Calais
dolphin again in court
Olivia injects lots of humour perhaps
trying to find some lightness and so
dark at times ninety 44 play play
Shakespeare calm Wright's pistol Robert
Newton is a joyful rogue you may
recognize him as Long John Silver in
Disney's Treasure Island few years later
he briefly impresses the Welsh officer
of flu
Esmond night but when he insults the
Welsh Fluellen beats him enforces in to
eat a leek the Welsh national symbol
Fluellen a know-it-all is not shy about
offering his opinions on how war should
be conducted unquote do we see here
perhaps another know-it-all from Ulster
named Allan Brooke Sue Ellen admires but
is conflicted about his boss thus also
Allan Brooke who wrote of Churchill
without him England was lost for his
cent certainty with him England has been
on the verge of disaster time and again
after he published those words from his
diary Allan Brooks and Giroux his
apologies parallels and inspirations
there's lots of these churches war
speeches are what shall we say inspired
by remindful of analogous to
shakespeare's example the enemy's
overconfidence before any firing
fighting takes place as the French
prepared to rout the English an officer
muses with some trepidation that island
of England breeds very valiant creatures
there Mastiffs around are of matchable
courage but the Duke of Orleans jeers
foolish curves that run winking into the
mouth of the Russian bear and have their
heads crushed like rotten apples you may
as well say that it's a valiant flee
that there eat is breakfast on the lip
of a lion it is now 2 o'clock but let me
see by 10:00 we shall have each a
hundred Englishmen animal analogies are
the things Churchill also deployed but
that's not the best connection here that
passage smacks of his speech to the
Canadian Parliament about the French
generals in 1940 remember how he quoted
them in three weeks England will have
her neck wrung like a chicken and his
response
some chicken some neck hard floor at the
Battle of our floor before as you Clark
Churchill writes in his history that the
British were badly outnumbered yet
foremost in prowess and Shakespeare
quotes the King once more into the
breach dear friends once more or close
the wall up with our English
I see you stand like greyhounds in the
slips follow your spirit and upon this
charge cry God for Harry England and
said George this is echoed in churches
war memoirs where he writes once again
we must fight for life and honor against
all the might and fury of the valiant
disciplined and ruthless German race
once again so be it and in his
preparation to his outer cabinet on May
28th 1940 the speech that ensured
Britain would not seek an armistice with
Hitler he said we shall fight on and if
this long island story of ours distended
lasts leaded end only when each of us
lies choking in his own blood upon the
ground you Dalton the socialist member
of the cabinet remember how his
ministers stood shouting slapping him on
the back while tears poured down his
cheeks and there's AP Herbert wrote mr.
Chamberlain after all was tough enough
and since the war began he'd been heart
and soul with mr. Churchill but when he
said a fine true thing it was like a
faint air played on a pipe that lost on
the wind at once when mr. Churchill said
it it was like an organ filling the
church and we all went out refreshed and
resolute to do or die on the night
before Agincourt King Henry towards the
English camp incognito to gauge the
morale of the soldiers seen his
remindful of Churchill's 1899 account of
the night before under man in the river
war and of his visits with the troops in
North Africa and before d-day and in
France but the closest closest analogy I
think is early 1941 that was when
President Roosevelt sent his confidant
Harry Hopkins to Britain to tell him
this the country was still worth backing
Hopkins traveled up and down the island
devastated by bomb damage he saw
everywhere he went he observed grit and
determination and faith and final
victory
Hopkins had no doubts Glasgow introduced
by Churchill he famously quoted The Book
of Ruth whither thou goest I will go he
said even to the end
Churchill wept back in London éva book
hosted Hopkinson and the press at
Claridge's Hotel we wondered to
Beaverbrook reporter said as our cars
advanced cautiously through the blackout
toward Claridge's what Hopkins would
have to say he went round the table
pulling up a chair alongside the editors
and managers talking to them
individually he astonished us all right
left and center by his grasp of our own
separate polished policies and problems
we went away content we were happy men
all we few we happy few too many who
heard or read his words FDR Beaverbrook
Robert Sherwood even J Edgar Hoover who
had FBI four agents present Hopkins
reminded them of Henry v touring his
camp before as in court with cheerful
semblance and sweet majesty that every
wretch pining and paled before beholding
him plucks comfort from his looks
thawing cold fear that mean and gentle
all behold as many unworthiness define a
little touch of Harry in the night we M
F Buckley Jr said it was not the
significance of victory mighty and
glorious though it was that causes the
name of Churchill to make the blood run
a little faster it is the roar we hear
when we pronounce his name as in court
was long forgotten as a geopolitical
event but the words of Henry the fifth
with Shakespeare to recall them are in
terrible in the mind I think that might
be true it is the words not the battle
that makes the blood run faster on the
eve of overlord in June 1944 general
Ismay was reminded of Henry's words
core he which have no stomach to this
fight let him depart his passport shall
be made and crowns for convoy put into
his purse this may hurt one parachute
commander say as he entered his plane
and gentlemen in England now Abed shall
think themselves accursed they were not
here that was a time as I've said when
almost every Briton knew Shakespeare in
the same act Henry tells his soldiers
old men forget yet all shall be forgot
but he'll remember with advantages what
feats he did that day in February 1943
writes Lewis Lerman Churchill
paraphrased those words the soldiers of
the 8th army who had defeated Rommel
after the war when a man has asked what
he did it will be quite sufficient for
him to say I marched and fought with the
desert army Churchill wrote in his
history of the english-speaking peoples
when one of the king's officers deployed
the fact that they had but 110 thousand
of those men in England that do no work
today the King rebuked him revived his
spirits in the speech which Churchill
was given a mortal form if we are with
Shakespeare has given an immortal form
if we are marked to die we are enough to
do our country loss and if to live the
fewer men the greater share of Honor
compare that to Churchill's greatest
speech June 18th
1940 if the British Empire and it's
Commonwealth lasts for a thousand years
men will still say this was their finest
hour it was no coincidence the historian
Jon Meacham writes that he tied the
trials of the present to the collective
consciousness of the world to come men
will still say was a call to arms
reminiscent of Henry v with the image of
how the tale would be told from
generation to generation this story
shall the good man teach his son became
be braved now in the future will cherish
your memory and praise your name an
impressive Mis risky means of leadership
for under stress not all of us are like
Bedford and
Churchill's history records the Kings
actual quoted words what you not he said
that the Lord with these few can
overthrow overthrow the pride of the
French he and the few it lay for the
night August 20th 1940 he spoken another
small outnumbered ban the fighter pilots
of the RAF never in the field of human
conflict has so much been owed by so
many to so few
remarkably Churchill in his speeches
never quoted from Henry the fifths grand
climacteric the Crispin's Day speech in
fact writes biographer Jeffrey best he
made far fewer historical and literary
references than a more commonplace
performer might have done but the effect
was to reproduce the congratulations
addressed by Shakespeare's hero to the
Englishman lucky enough to be with him
at Agincourt in his history Churchill
offers lines that are not shakespeare's
to describe the event the king himself
Churchill writes dismounted and shortly
after 11 o'clock at Saint Crispin's day
October 25th he gave the order in the
name of Almighty God an avant banner in
the best time of the year and st. George
this day b9 helped the archers kissed
the soil and reconciliation to God and
crying aloud loudly hurrah hurrah
st. George and Mary England since he's
written those were he'd written those
words already who can say the church who
didn't remember them on may 19th 1940
when he said our task is not only to win
the battle but to win the war for all
that Britain is and all that Britain
means more modern language but the
sentiments are the same in the movie the
constable of France leo
gen is not an empathetic figure he's an
arrogant imperturbable impassive and
phlegmatic and supremely confident of
victory then with the battle almost lost
he insist on returning to the fray and
dying in combat
I think Churchill recalled this
character when he wrote about the Gaul
during the fall of France
in June 1940 he tells us how among the
defeat is French he came across this
impassive imperturbable tall slag
mattock man on the last of those
meetings before France surrendered
prompted I think by a recollection of
the strongest French character in Henry
v Churchill said of de Gaulle here is
the constable of France and so he was
toward the end after wooing Katharine
Henry promises they will sire out of
saint-denis insane George celestial
patrons one of France and the other of
England a boy half French half English
you will go to Constantinople and take
the Grand Turk by the beard
Martha boob ESCO are remaining in
Princess in a good little 1950s book on
Churchill notice this comparison and
here we have she wrote in defiance of
chronology already predicted the day
after Agincourt the Dardanelles
expedition which in 1915 during the
alliance between France and England what
will be so near to Churchill's heart
she then cites words of the priest that
the author ye shall be two in one flesh
all those who knew him she writes would
be prepared to swear that Churchill had
this whole scene of Shakespeare's in
mind when he undertook that nuptial
flight on 11 June 1940 the man who came
that evening to ask for the friend the
hand of France in marriage offered her
people dual nationality with two
passports the right to vote in both
countries the pooling of the Armed
Forces in a word a true wedding unquote
that's a bit of a stretch Churchill did
not did make that offer but he had a
little doubt it would have much effect
or be accepted and it wasn't Henry the
fifth Tsuchida was not to last and
Churchill an old age likewise lamented
he had accomplished much only to
accomplish nothing in the end
and yet what a self description he
offers us in his concluding words on the
King written in 1938 not published until
92
thirty-six Henry he wrote was no feudal
sovereign of the old type with a class
interest which overrode social and
territorial barriers he was entirely
national in his outlook he was the first
king to use the English language in his
letters and messages home from the front
his triumphs were gained by English
troops his policy was sustained by a
parliament that could claim to speak for
the English people for it was the union
of the country that gave Britain her
character and a destiny unquote is that
not a description of Churchill himself I
think so
if only subconsciously that he meant it
to be his old friend Desmond Morton
surmised that for Churchill
it was always England and thus Churchill
was its man he had never moved away from
such a world it had caught up with him
from behind the back slipped in time
this was Henry the fifth and all the
great music of Shakespeare in the tribal
Sol he saw himself mirrored in the pool
of England and England in him
[Applause]
Thank You mr. lang worth has agreed to
answer a few questions please raise your
hand and wait for a microphone to be
brought to you
do I have to ask myself some questions
come on
you are wonderful as always thank you so
a few of us were discussing at dinner
what Churchill's position would be do
you think on brexit oh dear this is an
easy essay question I was going to talk
about that on Wednesday actually but
since you asked I sent myself an email
yesterday when I heard a rendition of
brexit that I didn't agree with and
maybe I can find it it's in the
Churchill documents of volume 23 the
last one there's 23 document vibes and 8
narrative lives in the official
biography which wraps up in June of this
year thanks to Larry on and the
Churchill fellows and in Hillsdale
College and I found this in the last
1951 he had just being elected so I can
find it
re-elected then was back in office and I
think I don't answer your question I can
find it
me brexit yeah here's me to me
first he said in 10 December 1948 we are
not seeking in the European movement to
usurp the functions of government I have
tried to make this plain again and again
to the heads of the governments we asked
for a European assembly without
executive power now that's quite a far
cry from what we have now but the one
that really got me was in 1951 as I said
he had been one month in office and he
wrote to the cabinet he said it might be
perhaps useful to all of you if I
outlined my position on the European
Union at Zurich in 1946 I appealed to
France to take the lead in Europe by
making friends with the Germans burying
the thousand-year quarrel Britain and if
possible the United States should be
associated with United Europe to make an
even bounce and to promote the United
Europe movement paragraph two as year by
year the project advanced the federal
movement to many Europeans countries who
will participate it became prominent it
has in the last two years lost much of
its original force the American mind
jumps much too lightly over its many
difficulties I am NOT opposed to a
European Federation including eventually
the countries behind the Iron Curtain
provided that this comes about naturally
and gradually but I never thought that
Britain or the British Commonwealth
should either individually or
collectively become an integral part of
a European Federation and have never
given the slightest support to the idea
we should not however obstruct but
rather favor the movement to closer to
European unity and try to get the United
States support in this work
andrew roberts and i have repeated that
over and over again since we found this
thank you for your insight tonight what
are your thoughts on the fact that great
leaders all come together at the right
time and this might have been one of
those moments in history and some of
mentioned perhaps our own constitution
and independence or also the right time
well we seem to manage it don't we I
mean I don't think this time is anything
nearly relevant to what we faced in
1940-41 but we do seem to get those
leaders when we need them I just don't
think the time is right for a leader
like Churchill to save the day again I
think we have what we think about it we
have much lesser problems than the Third
Reich so that's my own opinion came over
to fault Missouri and rode the train
down yeah with Truman and then you
talked about a speech he gave in Florida
I think after that has have those
speeches ever been the full text of
those speeches ever been printed other
speeches he gave you mean I know they're
all incomplete speeches to the 8th the
eight volumes by Robert Rhodes James I
think there are a couple of them are in
the Hillsdale document ones he went
didn't he go to Florida to get an
honorary degree and he said he was so
much impressed in his later life of
having received so many degrees as an
old man after having failed so many
examinations as a young one and the ride
down the Fulton was it was marvelous in
many ways Clark Clifford who was
Truman's aide told me about the way they
cleaned him out at poker Harry Truman
left to play poker and he got on the
train and Truman suggested we have a few
rounds intership said I'd love to do
that I learned to play poker in the Boer
War and Clifford said my gosh that was
amazing none of us knew when the
hellebore
and so they played a few a few hands and
it was it became very clear that
Churchill's play was not up to the
standards of Truman and these sharks
that surrounded in his press secretary
and Clifford as the other guys and so at
one point internment was down several
hundred dollars and he excused himself
and went to the laboratory and and
search of this brusque
frank frisk way we all know how he spoke
he said well boys it's pretty clear that
mr. Churchill doesn't play American
poker now he's our guest and I don't
think it's right that we clean him out I
think we should treat him better much
more clearly than we have and it's press
secretary Charlie Ross said well boss
mentioned somebody saying that to Trump
well boss should we play poker and
should we carry this guy and Truman said
well he's our guest I think we should be
nice to him and by the end of the trip
he won Churchill in 180 dollars and he's
very proud of himself and he said I saw
guys starting with three kings and Full
House and they throw in their cars so
it's a wonderful story because the
Bourbons story you know they found out
there was no Scotch on the train and
they stopped and so Truman offered him a
glass of whiskey and he said well for
instance what do you think of that and
Churchill said well Harry it's very good
but it's not whiskey and so they stopped
the train in rural West Virginia and
someone ran off to an all-night liquor
store bought a bottle of scotch make him
happy anyway sorry sergeant digress we
have a question on the speaker's left so
in Henry v you see the connection
between this great statesman shakes our
Churchill I was wondering you could talk
about the connection between young
Churchill and the Henry we seen Henry
the fourth if there's a connection there
or not because I mean we see Henry v
grow up to be this great leader but
having a rather rocky start as is eluded
to the 5th but is there some connection
between him from part 1 and part 2 of
Henry the fourth that we see in a
younger younger church oh I'm going to
leave that to Jim mullet who knows more
about Shakespeare than I do and that's a
sneaky way of saying I haven't the
foggiest idea Jim put that on your list
no I don't I'm sorry I don't know we
have a question on the speakers right
could you expand a little bit on the
immediate aftermath of the Battle of end
Anglet quart of what so at that time
England controlled normally northern
part of France and how long did that
Union last and how effective was Henry
that fifth at being able to control
those two countries I didn't go into
depth on my research of what happened in
the aftermath so I don't know anything
else our tative about it
but I know it didn't last long because
the next king lost it
burgundy was the last holdout wasn't it
I think it was is that right to him
right yeah and the lilies came off the
Royal Arms so it was a temporary thing
dr. Longworth I was Churchill known for
having other visions other than when he
was a young boy at barrows and saw
himself as saving the the British or it
would it was this something common
throughout his life referring to his
letter to a statement to David Milbank
his fellow Herodian at the age of 18
when they were just leaving how yeah
they talked to you
a good friend of his name no bank who
spoke with him about their future plans
of what they would end up doing and and
no Bank said well I see myself going
into the law I'll probably do something
dull and docile like that but what about
you Winston Churchill said he said I see
farther into the future than you do he
said I see myself saving London and that
a great disaster will happen and a
follower comin I shall be the one to
save London and this was in 1892 but no
Bank recorded that to Martin Gilbert
years later he thought it was
astonishing because he lived long enough
to find that that really actually
happened he did have a lot of prescience
he foresaw cell phones and as dr. Arnn
writes in his book about Churchill and
statesmanship he saw mobile phones he
saw artificial intelligence and worked
very seriously about it because he
thought we were eventually going to get
to the point where we were out educating
ourselves and reaching in the things
where we probably had no business but
that was in 1934 little did he know can
you imagine
Churchill on Twitter
I mean he was good at one-liners but he
memorized most of them your drunken and
I'll be sober in the morning he had to
eat lay that one away for the proper
time and it worked no he actually did
say that it's not one of the ones he
didn't say and everyone thinks he did he
got off a one-liner in Parliament in
1940 no after the war and Lord
Mountbatten heard about it and so on the
next next couple of days he said Winston
how do you get on come up with these
tremendous repast these stunners that
just take everyone by surprise and delay
them away he said patience Dicky I've
been planning that one for years so so
he wasn't as good officer cuff as his
son Randolph was much better
extemporaneous speaker but he did have a
phenomenal memory as these knowledge of
Shakespeare goes he and general Smuts
had a contest during the war about who
could recite the most Shakespeare and
Churchill course one but later on Smuts
realized that Church who have been
making up lines now can you imagine
off-the-cuff making up lines in iambic
pentameter I mean that's pretty good
innit but that's what's not said anyway
it's mutts time to heal yeah actually
one anyone else please join me in
thanking mr. Lang worth
you